Speaker 1: One of the things we did not get to
cover yesterday when we covered the wacky weekend
in Georgia with Trumpists and Marjorie Taylor
Greene and Matt Gates and all of these other
people, was that John Bachman, a Newsmax host?
I'm not. I'm not very familiar with John Bachmann.
John Bachmann was allowed, I guess, to interview
Donald Trump right before his speech on Saturday.
It is a bizarre interview. Trump looks visibly
confused. He doesn't, seems disoriented, and the
things he's saying make just as little sense as
Trump's physical appearance. Let's take a look
at this. Trump just uncontrollably lying and even
seems confused about the lies he's telling. Let's
talk about this lawsuit against Hillary Clinton.
Speaker 4: What do you hope to accomplish with
that? Well, they spied on my campaign. You had all
Speaker 1: of them there. Remember, there is still
no proof that anybody spied on his campaign.
Speaker 4: All the names are there,
all the names you've been reading about for
years. Bill Barr didn't want to be impeached,
and so therefore he decided not to do it,
which was a shame because frankly, you know,
you need courage to fight these people, deep
state or whatever you want to call them.
Speaker 1: But Trump still talking about
the deep state, I mean, fully in to so
many of these different conspiracy theories.
Speaker 4: I think we're going to do very well
with it. We have a great lawsuit, and I felt it
was really very important to bring it because
think of it, if I spied on that campaign, can
you imagine what would happen, John, if I now
Speaker 1: remember the lawsuit, as we
talked about yesterday, will go nowhere.
If the lawsuit were to proceed, Trump would
be subject to discovery. And the last thing
Trump would ever allow is for himself to be
put under oath and deposed. It's just the
lawsuits going nowhere. You guys know that
Speaker 4: by on their campaign on Obama or
Biden or and Hillary Clinton and the same thing
happened where we caught him because we caught
them red handed. If that ever happened. What are
they talking about? Treason? Are they talking
about the rest of your life in jail or are they
talking about death penalty? And these people
can't be allowed to get away with this right?
Speaker 1: So Trump, Trump suggesting that
something that didn't happen is actually treason?
Trump then seemingly blaming Joe Biden for Putin,
maybe using nukes. This is
bizarre stuff. Let's also talk
about Russia and Ukraine.
Speaker 4: Seems like
Putin may have miscalculated there.
Speaker 1: What is your assessment of where things
stand right now at Putin's invasion of Ukraine?
Speaker 4: Well, you never know. I can tell you
the country is just in shambles. You look at
these cities, they've been bombed and they've
been blown up, and it's going to take 50 to 100
years to rebuild them. And so many people have
been killed. So many people have been killed
and horribly wounded. But I will tell you that
it should have never happened. This would
have never happened. Had the election not
been rigged and this would have never happened,
he would have never in a million years have
done it. So it's very sad when I watch it. It's
sad because this is something all those people
should be living now. They should not be dead.
Do you think Putin would news use nuclear weapons
when you put him into a corner? And when you
talk the way they're talking, you know they're
talking weak, and yet they're almost giving him an
incentive. It's to handling him very, very badly,
in my opinion. I think that Biden apologized
again today. He's apologized. Every time he
makes a speech, he apologizes three or four
times a day for everything. He says, Look,
we have people that don't know what they're doing.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So anyway, if Putin uses nuclear
weapons? It is not going to be Joe Biden's
fault, and then lastly, Trump commenting on
approval ratings,
Speaker 4: I have no
idea if he's going to run. I can't imagine
he does well. He's got the lowest approval
rating in history in the history of a president,
which is pretty low. And if he does, and if I
decide I'd love to run against him, I can tell you
Speaker 1: who would be. Now, of course,
Donald Trump's approval ratings at this point
in his presidency were lower than those of Joe
Biden. So quite literally, all lies, it's
lies all the way down. And Trump just is
seeming very confused. When you look at him and
when you listen to him, it's all very bizarre